hi everyone welcome to the Khan Academy
homeroom for those olive or wondering
what this is this is just a a forum for
all of us to stay together especially I
was started when schools closed and
obviously summer I announced the schools
are continuing to be closed and you know
we can talk about what might happen in
back-to-school but talk about anything
obviously education topics but anything
that's on your mind and I'm really
excited about our guests that we have
today we have a very exciting
announcement from Khan Academy before I
get into that I will give my standard
announcement remind everyone that we are
not-for-profit that we only exist
because of philanthropic donations from
folks like yourself a special shout out
to several groups that have stepped up
right when they saw that we were already
running at a deficit before kovat and
that that's it grew because we had
increased traffic we were trying to
accelerate programs so special thanks to
Bank of America google.org faceting of
artists and 18t and many other
foundations and corporations that have
supported Khan Academy preak ovid and
especially during Kovach crisis but we
continue to run into deficit so any
support donation at any level is very
very much appreciated if you're in the
position to do so so with that I'm very
excited to introduce my colleague Megan
patottie who works with partners with
teachers educators around the country
and Megan we have a very exciting
announcement
what is reducing we do Sal we have an
exciting announcement we have just
launched our first course for teachers
in the United States and called
conferences to help teachers understand
all the things that are available on
Khan Academy for teachers I think
sometimes there's a you know an
understanding that Khan Academy has all
these great things for students but we
also have a lot of really great things
for teachers and so we wanted to bring
that to the forefront and so we've
created Khan for educators and it is
free just like the rest of Khan Academy
and available for educators everywhere
and because you know we've always had
many tools for teachers teacher
dashboards and reports and ways to make
assignment so this is a course to help
teachers understand all of these
different dimensions
they can leverage in their in their
schools or with their students
you got it Sal its to teach teachers
what it's like to be a student on Khan
Academy the course is set up the same
way our courses are for students so
teachers can learn what it feels like to
really be a student on Khan Academy and
then learn about you know a little more
about Khan Academy's mission about what
mastery learning really is about all the
amazing tools and content that's
available for teachers to use with their
students and then some best practices
that we've gathered from teachers all
over the country who have been willing
to share their expertise and innovative
ways of using Khan Academy in the
classroom and to share those out more
broadly and your point this course you
know it has what we call our master
mechanics tell us more about that so
there's a way for teachers to actually
not just kind of watch videos and look
at articles but they can get practice
and feedback on whether they've dropped
things or digested them yes the same way
we encourage students to practice and
demonstrate what they've learned we're
encouraging teachers to do the same and
so this course is you know founded in
our mastery system and so along with
videos and articles there are exercises
and unit tests for teachers to
demonstrate their understanding and if
teachers earn mastery on this course we
will provide a certificate of
recognition and right now we're running
a campaign as well for any teacher who
you know masters the course and complete
that and it is recognized as their
six-month ticket they're entered into a
chance to win actually a one-on-one with
yourself for whatever that's worth and
we can see some of the screen spot these
are screenshots both of our teacher
resources and also we saw a little
earlier and we see Meghan is definitely
one of the notable people in the course
itself on how to be able to go through
these these these teacher readiness and
for those who want to use it it looks
like we can go they can go to Khan Co
flash and all in caps k4 oh it's down
there at the bottom left if you can see
it I'll have to repeat it but I'll say
it actually k4e us
for educators us is what that stands for
and already we're getting some nice
comments and questions from YouTube
Suzanna Garcia Dominguez who's one of
our regular she's almost a kind of part
of our team now she's always had
interesting questions and comments when
she rose helps teachers understand and
organize great to have it all in one
place
best resource money can't buy there you
go
we'd like to believe that we are
invaluable but but it's glad to hear
that so there's one question and I know
the answer and I you know the answer to
but it's good to answer it because it
well the question is from Facebook
divita Hayes hatchette will this
eliminate the ambassador program I hope
not I enjoy interactions with my
colleagues in this role of course not
we are really grateful for our
ambassadors and for those who might be
unfamiliar with what the Khan Academy
ambassador program is the Khan Academy
ambassador program invites teachers who
are using Khan Academy really
consistently in an innovative ways in
their classrooms to you know join with
others who are doing similar things and
to share best practices and provide
training to their other teammates and
connect directly with the Khan Academy
team to share what they're doing up so
we can learn more about how we can
improve the product how we can support
other teachers and so absolutely not the
Khan Academy ambassadors are a huge
asset to our organization and definitely
a huge asset to me and I couldn't have
built this course without really great
input from a whole bunch of ambassadors
ya know we we often say I often say very
clearly if I had to pick between an
amazing teacher and amazing technology
for my own kids or anyone else's kids I
would pick an amazing teacher every time
luckily you don't have to make that
trade-off ideally you can create amazing
technology in service of amazing
teachers and that also applies when we
talk about how do we teach teachers or
how do we help support teachers human
beings are always going to be the gold
standard so our ambassador program and
our ambassador teachers are really the
rock stars out there who are able to you
know they live it every day they know
what it's like to be a teacher and they
our super users of Khan Academy so
nothing can compare to our ambassadors
in terms of being able to support other
teachers and how they can better empower
the students so yes it was a good
question you know I was surprised she's
like who's even thinking about that I
would never tell but just engaged that
that's out there no this is you know the
Ambassador Program is something not only
are we excited about we've been growing
about and if we could expand it we would
support it better we would love to
figure out ways we can do that so let's
see so there's a couple of fun questions
here
let's see we haven't never gotten this
question before from YouTube explorer
questioner Stalin Megan what are some of
your go-to brain fuel snacks right now
I'm having watermelon and broccoli
sprouts Megan I'll let you go because my
recommends are going to be more fringe
so people need time to breathe fuel
snacks okay so two different things I'd
say during when I'm in the office its
string cheese and carrot sticks which
sounds fairly healthy at home
it's definitely s'mores flavored Luna
bars much more chocolate I think that
pandemic has made my eating habits
probably a little bit worse yeah you
started strong with the cheese and
carrots it's very healthy you know and I
have nothing against the Luna
corporation but have you ever had the
sugar and caloric content not to make
you paranoid about those things but you
know you're anyway but but the answer
the same question yeah I mean there's
definitely that there's the go to snacks
my animal brain wants me to have which
is essentially just like me like you
know shoveling sugar into my mouth but
the ones that I try i've actually this
is my latest indulgence and this shows
that i have weakness Dysport for sugar
and i you know they're not sponsors of
Khan Academy in any way shape or form
but I don't from Costco I've been
getting these like keto ice-cream bars
that taste
you know most ketogenic low-carb stuff
does not taste good especially when they
try to make desserts this stuff is
awesome so anyway I I highly
that'sthat's been my my new thing is
my wife just planted it's actually right
outside the window like you know where
you can't see some planters with some
leafy greens and there's something fun
about just like going and eating them
straight from the plant like a like a
goat or something it's just like yes
fresh I'm getting nutrients so those are
I think those are my those are my my big
ones and I'm sorry for judging your Luna
bar I used to eat a lot of little ice
looked at and I'm sure I'm gonna get
letters from Luna I'm what the thing is
people use the word energy bars because
you know and like trail mix and stuff
like that because when you're going
hiking you do you do need a lot of
calories and you're burning it and all
that but then that somehow got conflated
I think intentionally by you know the
marketing machine that energy bar is
equal to healthy and but obviously if
you're sitting around you know watching
cartoons which I do a lot of exactly
alright so this may be slightly more
serious although what we put in our
bodies is a very important question
YouTube kirtana Nagala asks hello what
should we do to prepare for an online
test and reduced test nervousness make
it love love your point of view I'm
happy to give mine as well well what I
used to tell my students what I think
it's helpful is preparation if you can
prepare you know practice questions
similar environment set up practice time
sessions giving yourself the opportunity
to feel like you're in a real
test-taking environment and that you
have a grasp on similar concepts then it
takes away a lot of it what I would
often think of with my students as being
the intimidating pieces and so you can
you can practice what the parts that you
can control and you obviously there are
pieces that you can never control but
being able to practice and get yourself
more comfortable with the pieces you can
takes away some of that intimidation
piece so what do you what do you think
no I agree with all of that obviously
you can't understate the value of
preparation especially kind of
preparation that map's matches the
context and that you know goes into
something that's taken me a long time to
learn and I still remind myself all the
time is that you know in lies you can
get focused on the outcome or you can
get focus
the process and I think you know we
naturally our inner animals or egos
whatever we tend to get focused on the
outcome I need to get an A on this or
think about how awesome that would be or
think about how horrible it would be if
I fail this or and it's not just on
tests we do that with our careers we do
that with pretty much everything where
we naturally gravitate to the outcome
and kind of getting attached to an
outcome we're having a fear of a
negative outcome and that's almost
always counterproductive it's much more
valuable to get focused on the process
and then to say yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
do my best and this is kind of what you
were saying is like focused on the
process get your practice and then the
outcome is what it is and you know the
more and ironically the more you get
fixated on the outcome often times
they're not the outcome won't be as good
so that's I think the first thing and
that's true and you know I'm preaching
it I don't practice it in everything in
my life but when I do whenever I'm
getting stressed about something I'm
getting anxious about something I'm like
look it's just the process I'll focus on
what's in your locus of control
do it the best you can and then the
world will turn out the way it does no
point in stressing about it and then you
know if I'm if I were to continue to
preach I would tell people don't you
know don't underestimate meditation even
if you do 5 10 minutes a day should
quietly try to steal your mind have fun
with it be curious laugh about yourself
when you get distracted you're gonna
find that you know it's a lot harder to
take you know a lot of things as
seriously as sometimes we do in a good
way in a good way so going back to some
of the teacher training from Facebook
Robin Schwartz asks would you recommend
having this and this is you know what
we've been talking about around the con
for educators would you recommend having
this be a part of new pre-service
teachers training I would I would
strongly recommend that it and to be
honest the reason you know one of the
key reasons that we built con for
educators is because we heard and asked
from a lot of teachers saying I want to
be ready when my students come in the
door to my classroom I want to know as
much as I can before I get started and
so we've been working doing some teacher
training and support you know in person
but how could
reach more teachers to support more
students around the country and so I
would encourage teachers who are
pre-service I would encourage teachers
who are even returning to Khan Academy
we've really gotten some great inputs
from teachers all over the country who
have shared tips and tricks along with
diving deeper into some of our tools
that are available on Khan Academy and
even servicing some information on some
new changes we've made prior to back to
school this year so I would I would
deeply encourage pre-service teachers to
engage with the course and and feel free
to reach out to us with with feedback
and things that would be helpful for
future iterations yeah and from Facebook
Sarah Louise asks can you give some
examples of best practices I guess you
know like what are some of the things
you see Megan you visit a lot of
classrooms a lot of teachers and
obviously you've helped teach this con
for educators course you know what were
some of the key headlines the
CliffsNotes that you think are you know
when does kind of Caddy me getting used
best sure I'd say one thing that is a
misconception sometimes is that if you
have all these tools and you should
choose one and that's it and I think
what's really amazing about Khan Academy
is that you can use the course mastery
system set these long term goals for
students to work really on the mastery
of skills but also combine our Simon's
tool to narrow in on things that are
either curricular aligned or adding in
from another course or you know
supporting individual students on skills
or individual gaps that might be there
so using both course mastery and
assigning a long term pool and
supporting students through assignment
to hit a short-term goal so you can hit
all of your students with the parts they
need and we've got some advice from
teachers on on how to do that for a
whole class or small groups how some
advice I'm doing this in perhaps a
remote situation that a lot of our
teachers are dealing with right now but
really being able to combine and
integrate the tools that are on Khan
Academy instead of just looking at them
all in isolation yeah yeah so I have
this question this is
I guess there's one for me I'm not about
conch wanna ask Sal sir thank you for
very formal I'm not I'm not used to that
what is what is the one thing you
learned from all your homeroom sessions
during this pandemic you know I gotta
say there's been so much I you know when
I when I started this I didn't expect
that I would personally enjoy it so much
from a learning point of view I thought
just be a fun conversation but obviously
you know I think many of y'all saw the
conversation with Bill Gates that was a
little bit of an eye-opener we've been
reading or hearing a lot on the news
back then about kovat and how it's all
gonna play out but I think that was a
little bit of a wake-up call of how
serious it was and how long lasting this
was going to be so that was a big thing
I think Mellody Hobson Ray Dalio several
others you know just talking about the
economic implications and the powers of
the Fed and and you know the seeming
continued disconnect that we're seeing
between the stock market and what seems
to be happening on the ground and you
know people's everyday lives and why
that might be happening there's just
been a ton of people from Mellody Hobson
Francis Ford Coppola who talked about
their their life narrative and how they
got to where they go and that's that's
always a fun thing because a lot of
these people that you read about and
hear about your whole life no one often
asked them just like how did you end up
here like what were you like as a kid
and did you ever think you're gonna you
know win an Academy Award one day or run
a major [ __ ] company or or whatever else
I think the conversation with Bill Lewis
around race and what was happening I
thought was very eye-opening to me I
thought I understood many dimensions of
it but it just added
you're just a more personal dimension
you know especially what in clue dat you
know that whole incident that happened
in Central Park with the dog walker and
the bird watcher and kind of how you
know race was weaponized against the
bird watcher I think in a way bill
framed it I think was very eye-opening
to me I didn't fully appreciate what
what that dimension before other than
until I think we've done like 60 or 70
of these live streams though they're
there has there have been
a lot you know I think the conversation
with Fareed Zakaria went was very
wide-ranging a lot there so yeah and a
lot of the countries with our internal
team members obviously with Megan now
and then Marta you know we learned about
her journey and and I learned things
about you know team members that that I
I had no news I've worked with them for
many many years so anyway that's the
synopsis I'm really enjoying this
because I feel like it's I'm getting to
learn alongside all of y'all so let's
see so there's a from okay there from
YouTube Suzanna Garcia Dominguez always
asking great questions not to that we're
judging any of your other questions are
all great it's like you know what's your
favorite child that we love them all
will there be a fall pacing guide for
each grade level I can make and you on
tape stab back and I just say sound do
you want to share some of your thoughts
there first and then I'll add on yes
simple answer is yes well we're working
on it where we're at minimum there's
going to be a pacing guide that if let's
say a sixth grade student to be able to
say okay what percent mastery should you
be its milestone point over the course
of the year that's going to be there for
sure
and then we are figuring out or thinking
about our is the room for a kind of
deeper level of pacing guides you know
as you can imagine we're only about six
weeks out but I'm you know myself Megan
many other team members we're trying to
figure out what we could cobble together
to support as many as many folks as
possible because you can imagine most
traditional curricula are not going to
work well in a hybrid environment so I
think people do need help in and you
know what Khan Academy resources could
even be used on what particular days of
assignments above and beyond the mastery
pacing but Megan love love your thoughts
as well yeah I think what you touched on
is a lot of where many of our heads are
at right now and how to best support
students and teachers and this really
unique environment and I think one thing
that's really helpful that we're working
on is write those new get ready for
grade level math courses for third grade
through precalculus we're work
on how to support teachers using that
with students and how to help close some
of that learning loss that we know is
even wider this year and income for
educators and some of this additional
work that soundest mentioned that our
colleague Vicki is leaving we're working
on how to you know provide
recommendations on when the transition
from you know maybe using these get
ready courses to you on grade level
material because we want to help close
that learning loss but we also want to
make sure that students are getting the
oncreate available content we need and
so definitely something our hearts and
minds are on right now is providing the
best resources and recommendations we
can yep and there's a really comment
from you to explore questions or says
may the 4th is teachers day in the US
and September 5th in India this in case
you'd like to prepare your spoil or
prepare to spoil your favorite teacher
with gifts and appreciation one of our
team members says yes it's on our
calendar and I've had hopefully every
day is teachers appreciation day but but
yeah it would be good a fun may the
fourth in the US and September fifth in
India and I'm sure and if your country
does not have a teacher's appreciation
day hopefully it's every day but maybe
you want to pick a day out as well
hopefully yeah spoil your teachers they
deserve it absolutely let's see there's
a so Elena Goyal from YouTube is asking
how long would you recommend us to study
in a day so this sounds like a little
more of you know Elena's working
independently on Khan Academy I would
say in the summer well if you're talk
about Khan Academy let's say math I
think if you're able to put in over the
summer 30 to 45 minutes a day that's
great you're gonna you know you get
ready for grade level courses that Megan
was talking about if you're already you
know if you take the get ready for a
grade level course challenge and you get
a 80 or 90 percent then just go straight
to grade level and if you do that 30 to
45 minutes a day working at your own
time and pace I am confident that you
are going to feel very good the next
school year and you can just keep on
going if you're talking about studying
across all of your subjects you know I I
care more about that you are you always
get to engage in how
these things on top of your studying
studying can be healthy as well but you
know make sure you have time to eat
properly have time with your family
relax sleep and you know it's what it's
when studying gets in the way of those
things that you have a problem usually
that happens if you know there's kind of
a binge studying going on where you
procrastinate a long time and then you
know for two or three days you have to
you know the food the sleep the time
with family the relaxation goes away and
you just study that's less healthy now
we've all been there we've all done it
but you know it's healthier to pace
yourself out now to make it any anything
to add to that I would I would say again
right just what you're saying make sure
everything in moderation right yeah so
that's that's that's absolutely and look
I will speak very honestly as someone
who has trouble with moderation I mean
even the ether bars for taco I'm going
through them pretty intensely but yeah
my everyone who knows me in my life will
tell you I have well I have a moderation
problem even when even when I I can
sometimes even be extreme about trying
to be moderate but anyway that's the
whole other issue I think therapy
session for me so let's see there's so
she should Joshi please develop
something for kids to gain knowledge on
coding and kind of kind of be kids app
great idea it's not on the roadmap right
now but it's a great idea but I
recommend for the very young kids check
out scratch there are close friends they
have great stuff for younger kids and
then our Khan Academy coding I think
when students are about third or fourth
grade you can start to engage in it and
it's kind of syntactic programming which
is you know kind of programming that
programmers do so let's see
Nikhil go vendor hi sour Megan how do
you think the curriculum will change in
the future Megan and maybe I'll narrow
it how do you think it's going to change
for this coming school year because
that's what you know I don't think a lot
of folks are had a chance to even think
about that yeah I think it's a really
tough question that a lot of people are
grappling with everywhere from you know
the state level to districts to the
individual classroom and I think the
biggest
Challenge this year is he you know
teachers are used to dealing with the
Summer Slide or learning loss in the US
but now we have this you know extended
time where students haven't been you
know in the classroom per se and I think
the biggest challenge for teachers is
going to be how do I support students in
learning what they missed well also not
letting them fall behind from what
they're supposed to learn on grade level
and I think some sort of interleaving
you know previous skills and current
skills is going to be even more
prominent this year than we've seen in
years prior yeah I'll just add to that
you know your traditional curricula are
based on this notion of you have five
class periods a week that are fifty five
minutes long and that that kind of
states consistently through the year and
the teacher can check your homework and
then give kind of a well thought-out
lesson and obviously in this kovin world
whatever permutation it takes and you
know the permutation seem to be skewing
more towards what we saw in the spring
because Kovan only picking back up
you're not going to be able to do that
you know what the best cases we've been
seeing is teachers leaning on Khan
Academy both with the course mastery and
by making assignments so then they can
keep the track keep track of what
students are doing at their own time and
pace and then doing let's call it three
synchronous sessions over
videoconference a week maybe two of
those sessions are where teachers focus
on particular problem types that are
that they saw their students have a
particular difficulty in and then maybe
another session where they just answer
any questions students have and so I
think in this new framework which is
very likely to be at least the first
half of the school year but maybe this
entire coming school year that's where
you know to Susanna's original question
Khan Academy has all of the content
items that we think could be very useful
here can we make it easy for teachers to
assign them and maybe pace it out over
the course of the year they got it you
can do the course mastery and then you
know how and then what subset of those
assignments or the items can be used if
teachers are able to get on boom or
Google hangout to do those synchronous
sessions my gut sense is that's what
curriculum is going to look like this
coming year some teachers are going to
be able to go further than that
I actually think given how uncertain
things are if we're able to just get
that level where kids are able to get
pretty far in their mastery progress on
Khan Academy and they're able to do
assignment and the teacher is able to
monitor and hold them accountable
etcetera etcetera
I think you know given the circumstances
very suboptimal but I think that would
be a win given all of the uncertainty
that that we're facing right now so it
looks like we're all out of time I'm
making any any parting words for folks
before we leave huh just really excited
again to share that we have this
brand-new opportunity for educators all
over the US and that we are eager to
hear back from you and see you know what
do you think and what can we improve to
you know make things even better for you
so looking forward to hearing from all
of you
yeah thanks Megan and thanks you know
really special thanks for Megan and and
all the other people the Khan Academy
team who put together the Khan for
educators course obviously they've been
doing amazing work with educators the
amazing ambassadors for years now and
then this is just one more thing that
we're trying to do especially in the
kovat environment but to help support
teachers and then obviously there's to
get ready for grade-level courses we're
going to be creating kind of pacing
guides learning plan but we'll try to
get as granular as possible we're
actually working with a major kind of
think-tank consulting company on what
are best practices for back-to-school
for districts so we're trying to do
whatever we can and you know we know
this is going to be hard on parents on
students and really hard on teachers but
you know that's that's what we're
thinking about day and night what can we
do to support y'all and what can we do
it especially over the next few weeks I
also give a last shout out I said this a
couple of times as a side project
schoolhouse thought world that have some
amazing volunteers working on but that's
a place where you can get free live
tutoring and right now we have several
hundred tutors who are waiting and
really incredible tutors I have to say
I've been really impressed with the
folks that have volunteered so if you if
you know young people or if you are
young persons with these tutoring
especially in high school math right now
you can get some high-quality free
tutoring which you know
no strings attached that's all also make
that announcement so but thanks thanks
Megan for for joining and you know it's
going to be interesting next few months
but I'm
I'm lucky to work with Megan and
everyone else and hopefully we'll be
able to support all you teachers out
there as well as positive
Thank You sounds a pleasure thanks
everyone
thank you for joining and we're we're
now down to doing this three days a week
so I even the schedule eyes a little bit
but yes we'll see you later this week